bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors le nombre de
manifestants attendus seraient nombreux
bien qu'en raison de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire les rassemblements sont
interdits alors quel serait le message
envoyé en cas d'une forte mobilisation
pro
le message un sac et la liberté de
manifester reste sacré c'est une liberté
constitutionnelle et rien ne peut
compromettre cette liberté cette aux
autorités de prendre des dispositions
pour que cette liberté soit respectée et
bien entendu ça c'est dans le sens des
manifestants si je peux le dire ainsi en
essayant d'étudier leur moral leurs
psychologies
du côté des autorités c'est aussi un
défi de taille pour pouvoir prendre en
main une question qui est purement
contemporaine et qui a sa place dans
notre société la question des violences
policières et la question du racisme le
racisme en france existe depuis des
siècles c'est quelque chose qui a été
institutionnalisée constitutionnaliser
légaliser et aujourd'hui il a encore des
traces dans la société et mais aussi la
question des violences policières qui
est une réalité mise en exergue depuis
le mouvement des gilets jaunes et
jusqu'à ce jour ça n'a pas cessé
alors le gouvernement vous parliez de
violences policières a fait quelques
gestes en direction des protestataires
comme la suppression de cette fameuse
technique de l'étranglement
comment est ce que vous observez cette
décision est ce que c'est suffisant ce
n'est pas suffisant mais c'est une
décision encourageantes
ça ça veut dire déjà que les autorités
prennent en main à bras le corps cette
question puisque ce vent qui souffle au
sein de la société n'est pas anodin
souvenez vous qu'il ya quelques années
on a eu le vent de l'affairé stern ses
producteurs américains qui avait abusé
de sa position dominante en obtenant des
faveurs sexuelles des femmes et en
abusant de certaines d'entre elles
et quand ce mouvement est arrivé en
france avec le mouvement mythe où tout
le monde a cru que c'était quelque chose
de bien parce qu'il fallait changer un
peu des comportements c'est de la
société maintenant la sphère george frey
de dons l'étranglement la mort de
manière film est pratiquement en direct
à rim de manière saisissante avec la
situation d' adama traoré puisqu'on
parle adama traoré du pays 2016 mais
personne n'avait en fait
une image précise de ce qu'est ce garçon
a vécu comme supplice avant sont
savamment son trépas mais avec l'image
de george frey dont on se rend compte
que c'est que ce garçon a vécu et on se
rend compte de tout ce que les victimes
des violences policières subissent dans
leur chair et le pire c'est que lévis
coupe les auteurs de ces violences ne
sont presque jamais pu seraient
sanctionnés
donc les autorités doivent maintenant
donner un signal fort dans cette
dynamique mais aussi arriver à faire
comprendre aux policiers surtout aux
syndicats que ce n'est pas la mise en
cause de l'institution policière
mais c'est la mise en cause du
comportement des policiers
et là j'entends encore que les syndicats
fassent preuve d'intelligence pour
essayer de faire comprendre ce message
par miller connecte alors emmanuel
macron a demandé au gouvernement
d'accélérer dans ses propositions pour
améliorer la déontologie des forces de
l'ordre on en parlait à l'instant
comment ses futures propositions
pourrait-elle se traduire sur le plan
légal
sur le plan légal il s'agirait d'établir
des donner un cadre juridique formel
déjà par le fait de retirer
l'enseignement dé la pratique
d'étranglement dans l'enseignement des
deux polices informations des policiers
des gendarmes c'est déjà quelque chose
est très encourageant ça veut dire
qu'ils aient déjà c'est une pratique qui
est contestée qui n'a plus vraiment des
bases légales pour un policier qui va
arriver plus tard parce qu'il n'aura pas
appris ça à son école du coup une
désinformation et du coup ne pourra pas
pratiquer c'est ce geste lors des
interpellations feature d'autre part ça
veut dire qu'il faut travailler dans le
sens dames il a mené d élément concret
parce qu'il faut pas simplement supprimé
une pratique et laissé un vide puisque
les policiers doivent travailler ils
sont donc confrontés la leur dans leur
oeuvre quotidienne à des personnes
parfois violentes voire même très
violente
il faut leur proposer des mets sur des
méthodes alternatives ses méthodes il
faut les éprouver mais aussi les
traduire dans des instruments juridiques
qui existent qui encadrent le travail
des policiers mais aussi les travail des
gendarmes alors une réforme de
l'institution policière sera qu elles
suffisantes pour endiguer les problèmes
de vie
lancer de racisme présumées au sein des
forces de l'ordre ce qu'il ya d'autres
pistes a pensé selon vous je pense que
la réforme de l'institution policière
c'est un petit peu un abus de langage si
on peut le dire assez parce que la
police reste ce qu'elle est c'est une
police nationale à la différence de ce
qui s'est passé aux états unis
la police est national aux etats unis
les à la poly la police et dépend des
comtés et chaque comté peut avoir sa
façon son unité de police alors est-ce
qu'il faut réformer cela en
décentralisant la police je ne sais pas
je n'y crois pas parce que la tradition
jacobine dans laquelle la france est
très ancrée depuis plusieurs années
d'ailleurs notamment avec la présidence
des manuels macro ne permettrait pas que
cela puisse arriver en tout cas moi je
ne pense pas que ça puisse arriver de
sitôt ce qu'il faudrait maintenant faire
c'est travailler avec les policiers pour
arriver d'abord à mettre un terme aux
pratiques de certains d'entre eux
puisqu'il ya des milliers de
fonctionnaires mais il n'y a pas autant
des cas de violences policières pour
tous les policiers ça il faut le dire
mais ceux qui commettent des violences
les comètes de façon parfois fatales et
s'il ya mort d'homme comme ce jeune
adama traoré de mort à 2016 à l'âge de
24 ans d'autres personnes perdent leur
vie de cette manière il faut que ça
cesse rien ne justifie qu'une personne
sous soit arrêté soit puisse mourir
pendant qu'elle s'est fait arrêter il
faut pour cela travailler avec les
policiers pas la réforme de
l'institution policière
moi je trouve ces mois un peu abusif
mais à des réformes des pratiques
policières au comportement des policiers
sur le terrain et surtout à l'éducation
des policiers contre le racisme
merci beaucoup patrick em all you back
ont beau avoir rendu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes doctorant en
droit à l'université paris saclay